[Musik]
ein gehe alle testen und wir sind fein
raus man sagt irgendwie ist das
freiwillig sich impfen zu lassen
jetzt ist alles nur noch 2 gs irgendwie
unfair für die leute die sich dagegen
entscheidet das wird natürlich immer
schwieriger für die leute die nicht
geimpft sind sie denn es ist höher als
je zuvor und ich bin auch dieses zweig
plus modell was jetzt bald kommen soll
finde ich auch sehr wichtig weil einfach
nur geimpft und genießen reicht nicht
mehr
wird wohl richtig sein aber hat man
vielleicht schon früher einführen müssen
dann da waren sie mal wieder ein
bisschen langsam der regierung
herzlich willkommen auch heute wieder zu
einem zdf spezial
wieso verschiebt sich um circa 15
minuten
eher die inzidenz tten steigen und
steigen lange viele biologen sagen zu
lange hat die politik vor allem
zugeschaut und reagiert jetzt nur
langsam bevor wir darüber mit dem
geschäftsführenden gesundheitsminister
sparen reden robbie cherry an über
massnahmen kontrollen und sorgen auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt in ludwigshafen
freier zugang zum weihnachtsmarkt keine
zweig keine 3g kontrolle keine
beschränkung der personenanzahl so ist
es zur zeit in ludwigshafen nur welche
essen oder getränke kauft muss an den
buden abstand halten und maske tragen
das wird kontrolliert die inzidenz bei
213 für viele besucherinnen und besucher
ein sicherheits konzept das aufgeht ich
habe hier jetzt kein schlechtes gefühl
also ich bin beispielsweise auch mit
luca eingecheckt und so natürlich ist
ein bisschen selbst eigenverantwortung
auch immer mit dabei anderer großen
weihnachtsmärkte haben ja teilweise zwei
gene hat man keine chance als ungeimpfte
jetzt hierher gekommen und deswegen sind
wir jetzt heute hier und wir fühlen uns
sicher ich finde dass es für die kinder
auch ganz toll ist dass die auch wieder
mal ein bisschen normalität im leben
sehen es gibt da seit über zwei jahren
keine weihnachtsmärkte keine
veranstaltungen in jena wird es auch in
diesem jahr keinen weihnachtsmarkt geben
auch nicht mit zwei oder drei die
regelung die inzidenz bei
377 einige kliniken in der umgebung
könnten schon jetzt keine cupid
patienten mehr aufnehmen so der
bürgermeister in drei wochen werden dann
die zwei bis dreimal höheren heutigen
incidents werte in den kliniken auf
sagen und das ist nicht mehr zu
bewältigen und dann sagen wir während
auf der einen seite in den kliniken die
ärzte um das leben ihrer patienten
ringen und die patienten um ihr leben
kann man nicht gleichzeitig
weihnachtsmarkt feiern und damit die
pandemie noch weiter befördern für die
schausteller in deutschland sei die lage
extrem angespannt sagt ihr verband viele
stünden ohnehin finanziell mit dem
rücken zur wand sollten jetzt noch mehr
weihnachtsmärkte schließen oder gar
nicht erst öffnen bräuchten die
schausteller weitere überbrückungshilfen
vom staat und vor allem einen klaren
fahrplan
haben 16 verschiedene bundesländer 16
verschiedene corona schutzverordnung
dazu kommen noch mal kommunale
vorschriften und es wäre für uns schon
sehr wichtig die sache zu koordinieren
damit wir als schauspieler auch wissen
wo wir dran
deutschlandweit öffnen die
weihnachtsmärkte
ein hauch von normalität mit dem es
schnell wieder vorbei sein könnte
anderthalb jahre pandemie und die
situation dreht sich im kreis
und in berlin ist jetzt sehr entspannt
zugeschaltet genannt schönen guten abend
peter
ersparen die vierte welle hat
deutschland fest im griff und nach wie
vor gibt es kaum klare einheitliche
regeln man hat das gefühl die politik
schaut staunend zu warum reagieren sie
so langsam auf so extrem schnell
steigende zahlen nun wir haben ja nun
endlich möchte ich sagen eine woche der
entscheidung seit samstag sind die
bürger tests wieder kostenlos seit oder
ab morgen werden die ärztinnen und ärzte
mehr vergütung für jede impfung bekommen
am donnerstag wird der bundestag
entscheiden über die künftigen
rechtlichen grundlagen für die maßnahmen
und da ist auch die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von bund
und ländern also diese woche endlich
wird es zu den notwendigen
entscheidungen kommen um vor allem auch
zu einer einheitlichkeit die wir eben
auch brauchen für eine akzeptanz bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ja sie sagen es
endlich die instanzen sind hoch wie nie
kliniken warnen vor dem kollaps die
intensivstationen laufen voll haben sie
das nicht kommen sehen wissenschaftler
haben ja schon lange gewarnt
nun wir haben ja im sommer bereits
miteinander vereinbart welche maßnahmen
für herbst und winter grundsätzlich
gelten sollen das waren die aha regeln
im bus bahn im einzelhandel vor allem
aber auch 3g geimpft lesen oder getestet
etwa beim restaurantbesuch bei der
veranstaltung und die wahrheit ist frau
pieper 3g das war zu oft 0 g es wurde
nicht wirklich kontrolliert und damit
konnte ist das sehen wir heute leider
eben auch nicht den entscheidenden
unterschied machen um infektionen zu
erkennen und zu vermeiden also das eine
sind ja regeln die man sich gibt das
andere ist dann auch die kontrolle der
einhaltung und von beiden brauchen wir
offenkundig mehr ja sie sind
geschäftsführender gesundheitsministern
haben ob ein ende der epidemischen
notlage gedrängt ein fehler sagt ihre
eigene partei wenn sie jetzt mal
selbstkritisch sagen wo haben sie
versäumt zu handeln
nun ich hätte offenkundig viel früher
auch eine nervensäge sein müssen im
positiven sinne nämlich darauf hinweisen
müssen was uns in herbst und winter noch
erwartet und erwarten kann bei dieser
großen zahl an ungeimpften wir haben ja
immer noch 16 17 millionen ungeimpfte
erwachsene in deutschland und wir sehen
ja auch geimpfte können sich infizieren
aber die belastung auf den
intensivstationen die großen den großen
druck den wir in manchen regionen in
deutschland haben der entsteht durch die
große zahl an ungeimpften darauf haben
wir immer wieder hingewiesen aber ich
sage auch selbstkritisch das hätten wir
noch deutlicher machen sollen und war es
nicht auch ein fehler angesichts langer
schlangen von impfwilligen die
impfzentren ende des sommers zu
schließen und warum gibt es nicht mehr
mobile teams vor allem viele ältere
warten noch auf diese wichtige dritte
impfung
wir haben ja miteinander vereinbart bund
und länder im september die impfzentren
zu schließen und runter zu fahren als
sie einfach leer waren das war ja über
viele wochen kaum noch erste und zweite
impfungen stattgefunden in deutschland
alle die wollten waren geimpft für alle
anderen ist das auch in den arztpraxen
gut gelungen aber wir haben auch
vereinbart dass wir bei bedarf sich
schnell auch wieder hochfahren standby
hieß dieser betrieb und genau das
passiert jetzt auch alle länder
aktivieren ihre impfzentren wieder
manche machen das jetzt kleinräumiger
aber eben öffentliche impfen aufstellen
und die mobilen teams sind auch seit dem
sommer in den pflegeeinrichtungen
unterwegs um dort auffrischimpfung
anzubieten das ist wichtig und die neue
erkenntnis aus israel ist ja
auffrischimpfungen nicht nur für die
älteren für die vor erkrankten wo sie
zusätzlichen schutz geben sondern
auffrischimpfungen für alle sechs monate
nach der zweite impfung hilft diese
welle zu brechen die erkenntnis ist noch
nicht so alt die haben wir jetzt aus
israel auch aus anderen ländern
zunehmend und die wollen wir eben auch
für deutschland jetzt nutzen können sie
verstehen wenn die bürger zunehmend
genervt sind von der kommunalpolitik und
das verstehe ich gut das sind jetzt 18
monate im ausnahmezustand
und ich verstehe auch die wut die da ist
auch vor allem bei vielen geimpften die
eben sagen wir haben uns dann alles
gehalten wir sind den empfehlungen
gefolgt wir haben uns impfen lassen und
jetzt einmal mehr kommt es zu
einschränkungen beschränkungen zumindest
mal was auch zu erbringenden nachweise
angeht ich verstehe die wut gut oder den
frust die ungeduld und gleichzeitig ist
dieses virus so auch mit der jetzt an
stecken darin delta variante dass es
immer wieder uns auch vor neue aufgaben
stellt ich find es einfach wichtig
miteinander im gespräch auch immer
wieder zu erklären zu erläutern warum
wir sind wo wir sind und was wir jetzt
gemeinsam auch tun können und sollen und
dafür ich sage noch einmal ist die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch
wichtig bund und länder müssen endlich
wieder einheitlich reden kommunizieren
und handeln besser früher als später sie
sprechen es an die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
donnerstag welcher maßnahmen ganz
konkret müssten die denn dort
beschließen um die vierte welle in den
griff zu bekommen
was wir aus meiner sicht brauchen ist
zweig bundeseinheitlich wir brauchen
eine vereinbarung ab wann auch
zusätzliche maßnahmen in einer region
gelten werden hier unterschiedliche
lagen im land in sachsen thüringen in
bayern baden- württemberg teilweise in
den regionen kliniken die gar keine
patienten mehr aufnehmen können die
überfüllt sind aber im norden und westen
deutschlands auch situationen die
zumindest noch handelbar sind und wo die
dinge auch bei geringeren
infektionszahlen besser unter kontrolle
sind und dessen brauchst lage angepasst
aber in der vereinbarung ab welcher zum
beispiel hospitalisierung sin city dance
also ob die vielen neuen patienten cupid
19 werden dann noch weitere maßnahmen
ergriffen vielen dank entspannt sehr
gerne
das gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet
2g zweig plus mit tests oder masken
viele maßnahmen sind im moment im
gespräch wohl kommen wird 3g am
arbeitsplatz doch wie funktioniert das
in der praxis schon jetzt bedeuten tests
und dokumentationen für arbeitgeber viel
arbeit ein beispiel aus sachsen
zwei tests pro woche und hygienepläne
erstellen an die bisherigen auflagen der
korona schutzverordnung für arbeitgeber
hält man sich auch hier in plauen
oberlosa in sachsen wir sind beim
lebensmittelgroßhandel christel knoll
einem familienbetrieb mit 55
beschäftigten dass die korona lage nun
erneut strenge regeln erzwingt
frustriert den geschäftsführer es ist
natürlich ein bisschen schade dass man
genau das sind gleichen ausgangspunkt
jetzt wieder geschaffen haben und die
frage ist natürlich jetzt was kommen
jetzt an aktuellen regelungen und neuen
dingen auf uns als arbeitgeber zu und
wie gehen wir damit in zukunft um sicher
ist eine 3g riegel am arbeitsplatz soll
bundesweit kommt das plant die ampel
koalition nur genießen geimpfte oder
frisch getestete dürften dann noch zur
arbeit vor ort erscheinen offen sind
noch viele fragen was droht test
verweigern wer kontrolliert das testen
und dürfen arbeitgeber dann auch den
impfstatus erfragen hier im
überschaubaren familienbetrieb hat sich
das thema impfstatus schon von allein
geklärt
wir haben wir ein bisschen glück ist das
war sehr sehr offen mit der thematik von
anfang an umgegangen sind auch wissen
wie der impfstatus ist das natürlich in
freiwilligkeit besprochen haben und
dementsprechend darauf reagieren können
aber ansonsten müssten wir natürlich
alle 55 mitarbeiter täglich das in
blauen ist schon jetzt eine
mitarbeiterin ständig damit beschäftigt
die tests durchzuführen und zu
dokumentieren
dabei gilt 3g noch gar nicht und so sind
die erwartungen der unternehmen sehr
klar eine 3g verpflichtung muss mit der
kostenübernahme des staates einhergehen
dass die tests vom staat übernommen
werden und muss mit arbeitsrechtlichen
regelungen verbunden seien nämlich dass
der arbeitgeber seinem arbeitnehmer
bezüglich des impfstatus fragen fragen
darf und auch antwort bekommt schnelle
klarheit wünscht man sich auch in plauen
denn ich hier verschärft sich die korona
lager weiter mit einer inzidenz von
heute
man in münchen begrüßen rieke protzer
protzer täglich steigenden tendenzen wie
dramatisch sehen sie als biologin die
situation im moment ist man da nicht
fassungslos angesichts des langen
nichthandelns der politik
das ist man sicherlich ich glaube wir
haben oft gewarnt dass eine welle im
herbst kommen wird man hat ne welle
gesehen nach den sommerferien und jetzt
ist die volle granate da und wir schauen
im prinzip weiter hinzu wir müssen die
impfungen verstärken wir haben in den
hochzeiten mal eine million menschen pro
woche pro tag entschuldigt impfen können
und jetzt schaffen wir gerade mal
200.000 wir brauchen aber mehr wir
brauchen neue ersten impfungen und wir
brauchen vor allem die booster impfungen
gerade mal 11 prozent der über 60
jährigen hatten bisher die chance eine
dritten punkt zu bekommen das ist
einfach viel zu wenig bei der ja
abnehmenden immunität und es ist klar
schon relativ lange klar dass man eine
tritt impfung braucht dass es bei fast
an impfstoffen so und das haben uns die
israel ist ja wirklich vor einigen
monaten schon ganz ganz deutlich gezeigt
wir brauchen aber auch andere maßnahmen
um das virus abzuhalten wir brauchen
wieder vermehrt die masken wir brauchen
den ab stand wir brauchen die
hygienemaßnahmen und wir müssen uns an
das erinnern was wir einfach schon ganz
lange wissen a h l inklusive lüften
klingt doof aber ist das was wir einfach
wieder brauchen sie weisen noch einmal
darauf hin wie wichtig
auffrischungsimpfungen sind ist
deutschland denn dafür genügend gerüstet
im moment ist das tempo einfach viel zu
gering ich hatte ja gerade schon die
anteile gesagt wir müssen hier auf jeden
fall hochfahren wir müssen gucken wie
wir auch dem älteren menschen sicher
eine auffrischimpfung anbieten können
das macht keinen sinn dass die sich
jetzt ins volle wartezimmer setzen wo
alle anderen infekte gerade auch
kursieren der braucht man separate
termine
wir brauchen für die pflegeheime mobile
impft teams da müssen wir einfach jetzt
wirklich agieren auch wenn jetzt alle
ungeimpfte sofort geimpft werden würden
bis das wirkt dauert es ja mehrere
wochen welche kurzfristigen maßnahmen
bräuchte es dann ganz konkret im
gespräch sind 3g am arbeitsplatz und im
öffentlichen nahverkehr was bringt das
das bringt sicherlich alles ein bisschen
was aber
wir müssen wir haben bis selbst wenn wir
jetzt voll im von so stark oder so
effizient wie wir im mai/juni geimpft
haben dauert es vier bis sechs wochen
bis wir den effekt sie diese zeit müssen
wir überbrücken dafür brauchen wir einen
werkzeugkasten der uns einfach hilft es
zu tun und da gehören die masken dazu da
gehören kontakt beschränkungen dazu
gehören natürlich auch solche dinge wie
2g oder 3g regelungen dazu aber wir
brauchen diesen werkzeugkasten der zur
verfügung stehen muss der für alle gilt
und den mann dann einsetzt wenn man ihn
anhand der krankenhausaufnahme anhand
der lokalen incidents braucht und
idealerweise einigen sich alle darauf ab
welchem werden ab welchen grenzen man
welches werkzeug einsetzt weil dann ist
es für die bürger einfach viel einfacher
zu verstehen
papa zwar vielen dank nach münchen
ja das war unser zdf spezial mit dem
thema corona beschäftigt sich auch
gleich im anschluss wieso und um 20.15
auch der film die welt steht still einen
schönen abend noch auf wiedersehen
[Musik]